gros saucisson j format de papier très
simple lettre j oui tu agis juliette ont
ceci son format de papier le jésus jésus
doublement représentation du christ en
pole position
un jésus ceux ci sont de lyon par
excellence 50 points la lettre t
monsieur hémeury célia novopress presque
t d c'est un nom sensations produites
par le contact mécanique de l'objet ou
encore sentiment délicat des convenances
de la mesure
le tact très bien 60 points je pense que
vous continuez monsieur jean à lèvres eu
comme cursus on continue il s'agit ici
monsieur d'un nom je vous le donne
groupe d'écoles nommé suivant les pays
faculté au collège que dix universités
et dispensent l'enseignement supérieur
70 points rieux à la lettre v autrement
dit le score de marie christine vos
pierres et battus qui était de 70 points
la lettre x
vous avez donc monsieur les deux mille
francs à portée de votre main ils sont
chez vous dans votre portefeuille déjà à
en continu vous continuez traits d'un
verbe en vais remporter un avantage à la
guerre ou la portée sur macro ni 80
points double mais monsieur vous
continuez en continu continu
le w n'est pas le plus dur il ya très
peu de mots dans le dictionnaire ayant w
pour initial comprenait le mot
évidemment d'origine étrangère écoutez
bien moins anglais jeu de cartes ancêtre
du bridge et cetera